كانت هذه بداية
ردنا، وسيكون هناك المزيد من الخطوات، وبعض
هذه الخطوات سوف تتم رؤيتها وبعضها قد لا تتم
رؤيته ولكن سيكون هناك المزيد من الإجراءات
المتخذة للرد على
الوفاة المأساوية لأعضاء الخدمة الأمريكية الشجعان الثلاثة
و  لا يمكننا أن نستبعد
أنه سيكون هناك المزيد من الهجمات من
الميليشيات المدعومة من إيران في العراق وسوريا
أو من الحوثيين. علينا أن نكون واضحين
بشأن أن الرئيس في كونه
واضحًا بشأن ذلك قد أخبر
قادته العسكريين أنهم بحاجة إلى أن يكونوا في
وضع يسمح لهم بذلك.  الرد على المزيد من الهجمات
أيضًا وأود أن أقول من
وجهة نظر تايرون أنهم إذا اختاروا
الرد مباشرة على الولايات المتحدة
فسوف يقابلون برد سريع وقوي
منا، لا أستطيع أن أقول إنه وشيك ولكن
في النهاية هذه الأنواع من الهجمات
تتطور المفاوضات ببطء إلى حد ما
حتى تتكشف بسرعة كبيرة ولذلك من
الصعب أه وضع
جدول زمني محدد للوقت الذي قد يتم فيه التوصل إلى شيء ما
أو بصراحة ما إذا كان من الممكن
التوصل إلى شيء ما ولكن أه جالسًا هنا اليوم
لا أستطيع أن أخبرك أن الأمر قاب
قوسين أو أدنى